the wars in the middle east were a
complete failure but in the eyes of
lockheed martin these were some very
profitable years they made billions
the money moved out of your pocket at
the point of a gun through taxes and
then it was transferred into the pockets
of lockheed martin with a smile lockheed
martin made so much money in the middle
east that if he bought ten thousand
dollars in lockheed stock right before
america invaded in 2001 it would be
worth over a hundred thirty three
thousand dollars today a total return of
over twelve hundred percent more than
double the average stock increase in
that same period something you might
want to take a mental note of just in
case another war breaks out soon not
financial advice
lockheed martin is by far the biggest
war profiteer in the world by a long
shot and it got here off of scandal
after scandal after bribery accusation
and by profiting off of some of the most
expensive wars america and the world has
ever fought in fact they're probably the
most controversial scandal-written
defense contractor in existence it
exports planes blackhawk helicopters
missiles bombs to everyone from saudi
arabia to israel to south korea and
australia and it's not always the best
quality stuff
[Music]
but america is still its biggest
customer in 2018 u.s government
contracts accounted for 70
of lockheed's total revenue and for his
contributions the lockheed ceo made 23
million dollars that year
but despite all the production mistakes
bribery accusations and corruption
scandals lockheed martin still has the
u.s government in a chokehold the u.s
has just been forking out more and more
money to a company that lobbies in favor
of war has been fined countless of times
for bad behavior and doesn't seem to
mind overcharging the government on
almost every single contract it gets
this is lockheed martin the masters at
war profiteering
[Music]
in 1995 two companies merged to form
lockheed martin martin maretta and
lockheed corporation and the
relationship that formed between
america's defense department and
lockheed martin was simple the
government would give a ton of tax
dollars to the company and the company
would give state-of-the-art weapons to
the us what resulted was a lot of
opportunity for some serious conflicts
of interest and one of the biggest
factors contributing to this is a
massive revolving door right outside the
pentagon military officers generals
veterans would go into the pentagon and
once they get tired of the salary of a
public servant they would go private and
join lockheed martin in just five years
between 2014 and 2019 over 1700
high-ranking defense personnel left the
dod to join corporate defense
contractors because this is such a
well-known career path to take there's a
very high incentive to not piss off your
future employer while you're working at
the pentagon which means more
contractors favors and money for
lockheed then once these guys go to
lockheed they're the ones that would now
lobby for more war weapons contracts
increased defense budgets the pentagon
then has more money to play with and who
are they going to give it to their
favorite contractor lockheed and the
flywheel of war continues
this is what allowed lockheed martin to
pretty much take over the market right
from the starts unlike other companies
that had to spend years building up
their contacts to get a single
government contract lockheed martin had
everything going for them from the start
government contracts can be very
lucrative think about it by getting a
government contract you're getting the
best customer one with a big pocketbook
of money that they didn't earn so it's
very easy to overcharge them slip things
under the radar and more
there's a very simple rule when it comes
to getting contracts from the department
of defense you need to know people in
the right places that's what gets
companies like lockheed martin all the
good contracts while smaller innovative
defense contractors have to be happy
with the scraps just like in any
business a good network of contacts is
worth a million times more than a
perfect portfolio or affordable prices
and no one knows us more than lockheed
martin now in most cases defense
contractors send representatives all
over the world they buy people expensive
dinners spend hours on video conferences
building relationships that can get them
contracts and deals or for companies
like lockheed martin there's a much
simpler option just drop some cash
over their 20 years of existence
lockheed martin has been accused over
and over and over again of bribery
unfair lobbying and hundreds of other
illegal or borderline illegal actions so
much so that there's an entire wikipedia
page dedicated to lockheed bribery
scandals in places like germany italy
japan and saudi arabia a lot of this
happened before the 1995 merger but
those practices still got lockheed
martin into the right circles years
later here's how it works when there's a
new product they want to sell step
number one lobby to increase the defense
budget the more money allocated to
defense the more money the military has
to spend on new products the best way to
do this is by lobbying members of the
senate armed services committee the guy
is in charge of every year's defense
budget in 2020 lockheed spent over 12.8
million dollars on lobbying encouraging
senators and congress members to see
things through the eyes of a defense
contractor to increase defense budgets
create new defense contracts and to just
make the department of defense a better
customer and if lobbying for a bigger
budget doesn't work just switch it up to
supporting politicians who support more
wars overseas the deeper america sinks
into wars overseas the more money the
military is going to need for weapons
and aircraft so the more money lockheed
stands to make
step number two the sale now that the
money is out there and waiting lockheed
martin jumps into action activating all
his ex-dod and military veterans to call
in meetings get face time with people in
charge and find out what it would take
to win the contracts with wars raging
all over the middle east and more wars
brewing across the globe there's a huge
range of military contracts to pick from
so lockheed wins the best contracts and
money starts pouring in from there it's
time to explore another revenue stream
international sales
step number three international
expansion what's the best endorsement
any defense contractor can have that its
products are being used by the american
government the strongest military on the
planets the american military does all
the marketing lockheed would ever need
so now it's time to start selling that
same product overseas look at how great
the blackhawk did in iraq look at this
new amazing missile being used in
afghanistan
and sure lockheed's prices may be insane
and their techs sometimes questionable
but there's nothing that a couple
million can't solve in the pocket of the
right foreign official and with that the
product goes international being bought
up by countries like saudi arabia to be
used in yemen lockheed's entire business
model relies on people networking or
calling in favors or meetings at the
exact right time but that is not all
because once they get a contract it's
time to overcharge
[Music]
once the contracts are flying in it's
time to take the us government or any
government for that matter for all it's
worth and that's exactly what lockheed
does
lockheed martin overcharges over and
over and over again in 1998 just three
years after merging it had to pay back
three million dollars for inflating the
prices of radar parts then five years
later it was fined 1.4 million dollars
for overbuilding the air force in 2008's
lockheed's f-22a fighter plane was
singled out for cost overruns and then a
year later the pentagon said lockheed
will have to pay back part of the
massive cost overruns for the f-35
fighter jet projects and the list just
keeps going once you get your claws so
deep into the government defense
industry and you have enough contacts to
win whatever contracts you want you can
kind of just charge whatever you want
their business exploded during the war
on terror
which brings us to today where in 2020
alone lockheed martin received 75
billion dollars in contracts from the
pentagon even while the us was
withdrawing from afghanistan and scaling
down iraq more contractors kept getting
improved coincidentally many congress
members actually own shares and defense
contractors like lockheed martin
the military-industrial complex is bad
but the us government has seen much
darker days like the cia's mk-ultra
experiments where they forcefully
drugged people and did experiments on
them to try to achieve mind control in
some experiments victims would be moved
to an isolation ward where they will
only be given enough food water and
oxygen to survive then they would be fed
massive amounts of lsd and then they
would have helmets strapped onto their
heads with headphones attached blasting
messages like my mother hates me
hundreds of thousands of times
afterwards many patients would be unable
to walk or feed themselves if you want
to learn more about mk ultra we have an
exclusive documentary on them available
only to members of this channel all you
have to do is click the join button
below or click the link below if you
don't see the join button once you sign
up you'll get access to this documentary
another one on monsanto and new ones
coming out every month and if you join
and don't think it's worth it email me
and i will personally refund you in the
money click the join button below now
[Music]
you